AND SPEAKING OF THE PRESIDENT,
HE'S PRACTICALLY PLEADING WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS HIS JOB ON THE LINE?
BUT FIRST, GUNS, GOD AND THE
GRACE TO LISTEN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS, PARENTS,
BROTHERS, SISTERS, RAW EMOTION,
SUFFERING, SACRIFICE, BRAVERY,
HEART ACHE, EVIL, SORROW, ANGER.
17 DEAD.
>> THE NRA IS MURDERING YOU, OUR
FAMILY AND OUR FRIENDS ARE BEING
MURDERED BY THE NRA RIGHT NOW.
>> NO MORE PLACING NONSENSICAL
POLITICS ABOVE OUR LIVES.
NO MORE ACCEPTING DONATIONS FROM
THE NRA WHO SEEM TO CARE MORE
ABOUT THEIR RIGHT TO OWN THE GUN
THAN THE LIVES OF AMERICAN
CHILDREN.
WHEN DID POLITICS AND MONEY FROM
THE NRA BECOME MORE IMPORTANT
THAN OUR LIVES?
OUR MESSAGE IS SIMPLE, AND IT'S
NEVER AGAIN.
>> Laura: PEOPLE WANT QUICK
SOLUTIONS.
THEY WANT ACTION.
THEY ALSO WANT ANSWERS AS TO HOW
A 19-YEAR-OLD WITH A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS CAN SLIP THROUGH
THE CRACKS.
HOW DID THE FBI NOT FOLLOW UP ON
OBVIOUS RED FLAGS?
HOW THE SHOOTER HAD ACCESS TO A
WEAPON DESPITE HIS OBVIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IT'S ALL INFURIATING AND BEYOND
UPSETTING.
AND AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY,
THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT PARENTS
AND STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
TOGETHER WHO WERE GRIEVING FROM
PARKLAND AND FROM OTHER TERRIBLE
TRAGEDIES RIGHT HERE ALSO IN
D.C.
HE LET EVERYONE HAVE THEIR SAY.
>> I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO COME
HOME FROM SCHOOL, UNLIKE SOME OF
MY OTHER CLASSMATES AND TEACHERS
MY OTHER CLASSMATES AND TEACHER
TEACHERS.
>> THE SOLUTION IS NOT GOING TO
BE A SINGULAR THING.
IT'S GOING TO BE MULTIFACETED
AND IT'S GOING TO BE CREATED BY
A COLLECTION OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE
WORKING TOGETHER AND WE ALL HAVE
TO REALIZE THAT WE ALL HAVE OUR
OPINIONS AND TOGETHER WE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK TOWARDS
A SOLUTION.
>> Laura: WELL SAID.
THE CONVERSATION NOW HAS TURNED
TO BANNING AR-15-STYLE WEAPONS.
IT GUNS THAT HAVE BEEN CALLED
ASSAULT WEAPONS, OR WEAPONS OF
WAR.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I
COULD STILL GO IN A STORE AND
BUY A WEAPON OF WAR.
NAR.
I WAS READING TODAY THAT A
PERSON 20 YEARS OLD BOUGHT AN
AR-15 IN 5 MINUTES WITH AN
EXPIRED I.D.
HOW WAS IT THAT EASY?
>> Laura: MANY OF YOU REMEMBER
THE LAST TIME WE HAD AN ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN IT WAS FROM 1994 TO
2004.
THE STUDY OF THE VAN THAT WAS
DONE BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF JUSTICE CONCLUDED THAT THE
BAND PRODUCED NO DISCERNIBLE
REDUCTION IN THE LETHALITY AND
INJURIOUS NOTICE OF GUN VIOLENCE
INJURIOUS NOTICE OF GUN VIOLENC
VIOLENCE.
IT WENT ON TO NOTE THAT ASSAULT
WEAPONS WERE RARELY USED IN GUN
CRIMES, EVEN BEFORE THE BAN.
LOOK, THERE ARE CLOSE TO
15 MILLION AR-15 STYLE RIFLES IN
THE UNITED STATES TODAY.
IT'S ONE OF THE TOP-SELLING
STYLE OF WEAPONS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND IT MAY BE HARD TO BELIEVE,
ESPECIALLY AFTER LAST WEEK,
THESE GUNS ARE ACTUALLY RARELY
ACCORDING TO THE FBI, RIFLES OF
ALL KINDS, NOT JUST THE SEMI
AUTO TYPES, ACCOUNTED FOR JUST
3% OF FIREARMS HOMICIDES IN 2016
WHILE HANDGUNS ACCOUNTED FOR
65%.
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU HEAR IN THE
MEDIA, HANDGUNS ARE ALSO STILL
BY FAR THE WEAPON OF CHOICE FOR
MASS SHOOTERS DEPENDING ON THE
DEFINITION, IT'S WHEN THREE OR
FOUR OR MORE A PEOPLE ARE
KILLED.
EVEN LEFT-WING MEDIA OUTLETS,
YOU SEE THE GRAPHIC THERE FROM
THINGS LIKE MOTHER JONES -- FROM
1982 THROUGH 2,012 FOUND THAT
66% OF THE WEAPONS WERE HANDGUNS
WHILE JUST 14% WOULD QUALIFY AS
ASSAULT WEAPONS ACCORDING TO THE
DEFINITION USED BY GUN-CONTROL
ADVOCATES.
NOW JACOB SOLOMON AFFIRMS THAT
BANNING ASSAULT WEAPONS WILL
SIMPLY NOT STOP MASS KILLINGS.
"POLITICIANS, ACTIVISTS AND
JOURNALISTS WHO HAVE DECIDED TO
BLAME MASS SHOOTINGS ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS EITHER DO NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THESE FACTS OR WAVE
THEM AWAY.
IT IS CLEARLY POSSIBLE TO CARRY
OUT ATTACKS SIMILAR TO LAST
WEEK'S WITHOUT USING ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
NINE OF THE MASS SHOOTINGS WITH
THE 20 HIGHEST DEATH TOLLS IN
BOTH HANDGUNS OR LONG GUNS THAT
ARE NOT COVERED BY THE FEINSTEIN
BILL.
THAT INCLUDES THE THIRD
DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING, WHICH
KILLED 32 PEOPLE AT
VIRGINIA TECH IN 2007, AS WELL
AS TWO OTHER ATTACKS THAT KILLED
17 OR MORE PEOPLE."
"GQ" MAGAZINE, NOT EXACTLY A
CONSERVATIVE OUTLET ADDRESSED
THE SAME ISSUE A FEW YEARS AGO
AND IT AGREED NOTING THAT EVEN
THE DEMOCRATIC STAFFERS WHO
WROTE THE NOW-EXPIRED 1994
FEDERAL ASSAULT WEAPON BAN KNEW
IT WAS A LARGELY SYMBOLIC POLICY
IT WAS A LARGELY SYMBOLIC POLIC
POLICY.
PERHAPS THE MOST POIGNANT WORDS
TODAY CAME FROM A FATHER, ANDREW
POLLOCK, WHO BURIED HIS DAUGHTER
MEADOW JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
FLANKED BY HIS SONS, HIS RAGE,
AND HIS FRUSTRATION WAS EVIDENT.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE, FIX
IT.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ONE SCHOOL
SHOOTING AND WE SHOULD HAVE
FIXED IT!
AND I'M PISSED, BECAUSE MY
DAUGHTER I'M NOT GOING TO SEE
AGAIN!
SHE'S NOT HERE.
WE ALL WORK TOGETHER TO COME UP
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA, SCHOOL
SAFETY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT GUN LAWS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Laura: THE FOCUS SHOULD BE
ON SCHOOL SECURITY.
THE SOFT TARGETS THAT ARE SO
VULNERABLE TODAY.
ARMING STAFF WHO ARE
WELL-TRAINED, GETTING
AUTHORITIES ON THE STATE, LOCAL
AND FEDERAL LEVEL TO SEE THE
OBVIOUS WARNING SIGNS AND ACT ON
THEM AND THIS OBVIOUS FACT THAT
AMERICA HAS BECOME A SOCIETY OF
STRANGERS, DISTANT THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA.
ALL THOSE ANONYMOUS INSULTS AND
CONDEMNATIONS ARE OFTEN UNDULY
HARSH AND DISCONNECTED.
>> WE MUST CREATE A CULTURE OF
CONNECTEDNESS.
WE MUST CREATE A CULTURE IN
WHICH OUR CLASSMATES BECOME OUR
FRIENDS.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS HAVE BEEN FROM YOUNG
MEN FOR DISCONNECTED.
>> Laura: LET'S NOT DISCOUNT
THIS FACT, THAT WHILE SCHOOLS
OBSESS ABOUT DIVERSITY,
SOMETIMES THAT ONLY BREEDS
TRIBALISM.
AND SOCIAL MEDIA, AS I
MENTIONED, CREATES NOT A
COMMUNITY, BUT A FORCED
DISTANCE, A SENSE OF LONGING,
EVEN ENVY.
SO MAYBE IT'S TIME TO LISTEN TO
WHAT STEVE'S POLICE LAST WEEK
AFTER THE SHOOTING AND PARKLAND.
PRAYER WORKS, HE SAID.
GETTING BACK TO THE BASICS.
COMMON SENSE, FAMILY,
FRIENDSHIPS AND BELIEF THAT GOD
LOVES US ALL NO MATTER WHAT WE
ARE GOING THROUGH.
THINK ABOUT THAT STUDENT PETER
WANG AND WHAT HE SHOWED US.
WHAT HE SACRIFICED HIMSELF.
HE WAS ONLY 15 YEARS OLD BUT HE
HELPED SAVE NUMEROUS FELLOW
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS BY FIRST
USHERING THEM TO SAFETY.
HIS TRAINING ALREADY KICKED IN.
AMIDST ALL THE CRIES FOR CHANGE
AND LEGISLATION, HIS EXAMPLE IS
THE ONE I HOPE MORE OF US
EMULATE.
THE PRESIDENT DID A REALLY GOOD
THING TODAY.
BUT AS WE SEEK TO LEARN FROM
THESE HORRIFIC TRAGEDIES AND FIX
WHAT WE CAN, EMOTION CANNOT AND
SHOULD NOT EVER OVERRIDE OUR
CONSTITUTION.
WE MUST RESPECT THE RIGHTS THAT
OUR CREATOR GAVE US, YES, THE
SECOND AMENDMENT'S RIGHT TO KEEP
AND BEAR ARMS, AND ALSO OUR
RIGHT TO LIFE, LIBERTY, AND THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
THOSE 17 STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
WHO ARE NO LONGER WITH US, THEY
DON'T HAVE EITHER OF THOSE
RIGHTS, NOT THE SECOND AMENDMENT